[Music]
and I'm pleased to be sharing this new
day with Savannah Guthrie who after
several years of playing a great role on
this program takes a step forward this
morning and joins us as co-anchor of
today since July 9th 2012 Matt Lauer and
Savannah Guthrie have grown close as
co-anchors on The Today Show but their
professional relationship was rocked to
the core last week after Lauer was fired
over sexual misconduct allegations
Guthrie revealed the news live on the
air we are heartbroken I'm heartbroken
from Matt he is my dear dear friend and
my partner since Lauer's termination a
source told ET that Guthrie has been
deeply affected explaining quote she's
not herself she's visibly shaken they
are devastated and we are still
processing all of this the former
colleague shared many memorable moments
together on-air including wearing wacky
Halloween costumes and hosting the
Rockefeller Center tree lighting
ceremony in March Lauer gushed over
Guthrie's family when they made a
surprise appearance it's so great to see
you guys it really is and he's growing
so well and in July
Lauer praised Guthrie while celebrating
her five years of anniversary on today
I think Savannah is one of the most well
rounded people / personalities on the
program I pick her brain a lot when it
comes to politics
[Music]